ban a déjà fait ouvrez cité hier soir
aujourd'hui on se fait tous chier c'est
exactement ça yo tout le monde sait
squeeze champions se retrouvent sur
within gypsy rose un jeu d'horreur à
c'est vraiment vraiment vraiment
flippant qui est sorti l'année dernière
ces parties planes rigaux bon je vous
résume ce qui vient d'être dit en gros
il ya une sorte de démon qui le poursuit
dans ses rêves et un gros bas du coup il
va juste affronter ce cauchemar en face
et trouver un objet qui lui est propre
voilà c'est parti
dreamhack est ce que je dois faire alors
ça c'est un petit délire je me suis tout
seul dans ma tête bien évidemment c'est
pas comme ça en jeu aaa à aa que vois-je
que vois-je des lucioles qui joue à
sortir de ma couette très bien papillon
sur eux pour dormir
je pense qu'on va aller dans son fameux
rêve ou là ou là ok bon on peut pas se
déplacer plus vite que ça pas rallume
toi rallume toi tout de suite où je vais
pas dans l'école femme puisse pas y la
lune z et c'est ici la soirée comme ça
je t'ai vu je t'ai vu qu'il est tu tues
je ne sais pas mais je m'en vais à ben
on va rentrer un parce qu'apparemment
nous attend sa soeur sophie trop bien
dans ce genre de cas parce que dans les
jeux dans les films d'horreur les mecs
sont bat les couilles ils vont ils tous
personnellement j'aurais plutôt fait
cette technique à yann lumière à tous
les coups la clé est dans la poubelle
non que dalle ok un mur invisible dont
ceux de l'autre côté je me suis bien
dessus dit il calmement à voilà donc je
parle tout seul voilà salut hommes de la
fenêtre
voilà j'espère qu'ils me répondra dans
le chat la débilité bon et la clé là
j'aimerais bien trouver la clé bordel de
merde un piper clip art fossé pont est
bon on n'a qu'à chanter une comptine
pour enfant pendant qu'ils aient place à
deux à l'heure
[Musique]
c'est là qu'on n'ouvre la porte et qu'on
voit masse d'étudiants en train de faire
la fête du nouvel an à 2 3 'cela fait à
merde hein rentrer à tokyo j'entends la
musique pas vous ok c'est pas du tout
comme je le pensais est ce qu'on peut
lire qu on sait qu as-tu actuellement
bien évidemment à ça va alors si on peut
ouvrir les portes tout va bien aux audi
puis cgem pas fait exprès quoi il aurait
pu mettre une voix et qu'ils aient une
annonce publicitaire que c'était très
triste il est aussi co est un truc là
dedans je sais qu'un truc là dedans ne
me manque pas je peux appuyer sur eux
laborde s'est fermé ah bah ça va alors
un heureusement que j'ai allumé et
lumière un âgé moins peur tout de suite
aller les enfants ouvrent et vocale est
mat page 18 ans puis s'il ya vraiment ça
dans les salles de cours ces espèces de
[ __ ] de carreaux et là et moi je me
suis arrivé tout les gros gogol de ma
classe qui faisaient ça donc je vois en
tant que geek un mât damien ya un débile
mental à la porte l'alien débile mental
ça c'est comme ça moi bon allez on sort
ok ok aux deux tu fais pas ça hein tu me
respectes ok ils ont le respect bonjour
comment ça va ça c'est une poubelle
géante voilà ce moyen wattao question
c'était juste l'ombre d'une chaise
excuse moi mais [ __ ] mais c'est quoi
ce ive pourquoi il est là qu est ce qu
il veut quoi hein pourquoi tu fais des
reflets comme ça ok c'est y danse
regarder eh bien écoutez on n'a pas
d'autre choix que d'aller vers cet
endroit méga glauque
on va se calmer siouplait ça va c'est
pas trop glauque qui ça se passe bien
aava remettre le courant comme en mille
courant je me sens bien c'est notre qg
allait fermer cette porte et et dormons
ouais carrément sa part sur un basket et
là on voit un mec qui sur la touche
depuis 55 ans
un [ __ ] de squelette il aura passé sa
vie sur la touche bon y'a rien dans
cette salle de merde allons nous en il
ya un petit bout il ya un [ __ ]
bougeait pas il ya un [ __ ] de bruit de
mr diop et un bruit de mer et là c'est
nous le mec des villes qui fait chier la
classe alors y avoir à la profondeur je
me cache
excusez moi quelqu'un pourrait pousser
ses décors un peu chiant personnes
parfait ça me va et votre problème
je parle le seul à l'eau quelqu'un est
là le mec suscitait le monde si tu parle
tout seul dans un chat
useless qu'à peine 10 mois c'est quoi ça
ah c'est quoi ça ressemble différent de
chavin et kevin met à réviser mais c'est
un pénis du tyrannosaure kevin
ah bah ça va alors ah bah ça va alors si
une porte se ferme devant nous tout va
bien ça va
[ __ ] mais c'est méga glaude bordel 2
rallume toi faut trop de pression ah bah
ça va alors on a trouvé quelque chose
studio de profil kevin attention j'ai
ton dossier scolaire entre les marques
et l'hymne à voile à kevin ya un mec qui
pleurait bien entendu le gros barbu qui
pleure tu peux venir si tu veux ok on va
devoir repartir vers la balle et à
gauche mode à c'était le casier divin il
est apparu comme ça devant nous ok la
georgette voient un moyen de mettre fin
à notre vie à aller jeter plus qu'un
style festif le casse malheureusement
c'était pas possible
salut jean louis david up ok il a mis
une chaise
qu'est ce qu'on fait what are what aph
ok [ __ ] c'est la vieille nouvelle gens
qui me fait peur excusez moi je viens
prendre la preuve sur ce chariot pour
lui dire de bien les faire [ __ ]
c'est cool de faire a pas d'échelle sans
je veux dire c'est un don exceptionnel
mais est ce qu'on s'en bat les couilles
oui et ce qu'est ce qu'on fait kevin que
la force de kevin sont avec nous à
tarbes plus que le dernier et on tient
quelque chose doit pouvoir accéder aux
toilettes c'est magnifique bon j'aurais
bien aimé qu'une ag dire qu'à une instru
magnifique se manifeste puis c'est que
ça a
il fait le truc d'hugo laporte aaa vous
voyez oui on n'est pas les seuls bémols
et gelé leur faut qu'est ce qu'il ya ok
donc oui ok c'est quoi cette injustice
ok les wc allez je me suis bien sûr
caféine café con ou quoi tout ça sur la
chaise sur une route à deux journaux
bien pourri à côté des quasi moisi avec
kevin bon les temps ont changé voilà
nous ont joué à envoyer des cartouches
d'encre au plafond eux ils jouent à
casser le sol
ah non mais ça ne bloque très bien moi
je pensais qu'il allait enfin se passer
un truc après après 20 minutes mais que
dalle
y a rien dans les casiers rien dancing
non à une
c'était quoi ce bruit pour son agression
lui met un coup de génie bars et ses
filles assez pour réparer peut-être le
truc en eau ou alors peut-être pour
accéder aux chiottes c'est la clé des
toilettes la tulipa j'aimerais accéder
aux sanitaires s'il vous plaît très bien
peut-être ici à super voilà on est tout
seul 1
mais c'est pas pour autant qu'on peut
pas faire la fête
[Musique]
e s que y'a pas un truc dans le coup
classique 2 à o o
oh la vache oh oh c'est bon à la clé on
a la clé pour accéder ou je ne sais même
pas où tourner une clé quand toutes les
toilettes sont prises il te reste le
coin ça crie alors à quoi sert cette clé
ne ouvrir à petit voilà c'est normal ce
qui va se passer là c'est quoi ce bordel
donc la porte a été ouvert très bien
aucun butin par contre dès que des cas
lumière s'éteint je vous cache pas on
fait une sorte de mini arrêt cardiaque
watts vous avez été vus je bouge plus je
m'en bats les steaks voilà j'en ai rien
à [ __ ] c'est la fin je met en position
foetale
vous avez été vus non mais non mais les
mecs me fait passer à bordel et j'ai
plus accès à ma l'offre alors je doute
qu'on puisse boucher une fuite avec une
clé on va tenter quand même très bien ok
moi c'était jouable
c'était jouable boiziot s'en va et c'est
elle qu'on va aller là-bas au fond un
opulent ce fonds serait dépensée par un
démon ah ah ah
what salue ses pairs de kevin qui est
pas content oui je les coûts pourquoi je
suis dessus ou pour vous c'est bon on a
finalement réussi hier
ok on est punis au cachot
les moutons je tenais